[موسيقى]
يتحدث الجميع عن Tesla Model 3 ،
وهي السيارة الكهربائية الكبيرة في السوق في
الواقع ، كانت نيسان موجودة قبل فترة طويلة
مع Leif والآن أصبحت ورقة 2018 الجديدة
أطول في تلك السيارة بالإضافة إلى أنها
لا تزال تحصل على سعر أقل في  Tesla
Model 3 أو Chevy ball TV ،
تبدأ الورقة بحوالي ثلاثين ألف دولار
أي أقل بحوالي خمسة آلاف دولار من
تلك السيارات ، لكنها أيضًا لا تمنحك
نفس النطاق تمامًا مثل النطاق
المجاني وسيأخذك تلفزيون الكرة إلى أبعد من ذلك
رسم بياني على الرغم من أن نيسان تقول أن
إصدارًا أغلى قليلاً من الأسبوع
بنطاق مثل هؤلاء الرجال الآخرين سيأتي
قريبًا ، تثبت تسلا أن السيارات الكهربائية
يمكن أن تكون ممتعة للغاية لقيادة Nissan Leaf ،
إنه أمر ممتع ، إنه شيء رائع في
هذه السيارة يمر  دواسة واحدة للقيادة
إلا في حالات الطوارئ ، لا أحتاج أبدًا إلى
لمس دواسة الفرامل ، حتى أنني أستطيع
التوقف تمامًا عن طريق رفع قدمي
عن دواسة الوقود ، شيء آخر
فوجئت بإيجاده في مساعد Leaf pro التجريبي ،
إنه نوع من  مثل
إصدار نيسان من Tesla autopilot ، فهو يساعدك على
البقاء في مسارك والحفاظ على مسافة آمنة
من السائقين الآخرين. الكثير من
السيارات لديها هذه الأشياء الآن ولكن معظمها من
الطرازات الفاخرة من العلامات التجارية مثل مرسيدس
أو بي إم دبليو مثيرة للإعجاب للغاية للعثور عليها في
نيسان الورقة  هي سيارة ذات مظهر لائق
من الخارج ، فهي لن تلفت
الكثير من الرؤوس لكنها لا تجعلك
تريد أن تنظر بعيدًا سواء كان الداخل
قصة مختلفة
آسف لكنها تبدو مجرد سيارة رخيصة
الآن السيارات الكهربائية
جزء صغير من السوق بحلول نهاية
العام سيكونون جزءًا صغيرًا أكبر
من السوق وربما يتساءل الكثير من الناس
عما إذا كانت القيادة
الكهربائية بالكامل ستكون عملية
بالنسبة لهم بشكل جيد مثل نيسان
ليف مع الركبتين  إلى سلسلة الجبال ،
السعر المنخفض نسبيًا يجعل الحالة أن
السيارة الكهربائية يمكن أن تعمل
لعائلة نموذجية
لك